ومشاهدينا الكرام ارحب بكم من جديد في
سلسله اللقاءات على هامشي قمه جده في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه يسعدنا في هذا
اللقاء ان نرحب بنائب رئيس الوزراء وزير
الخارجيه العراقي معالي السيد فؤاد حسين
اهلا بك معنا
طالما نحن في جده وعلى هامش قمه جده كيف
تنظر الى هذه القمه
كوزير خارجيه العراق كيف تنظر دوله العراق
للقمه التي
احتضن سوريا لاول مره منذ 12 عاما
طبعا هذه القمه قمه مهمه اولا لانها تناقت
في جده وفي السعوديه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ثانيا قمه لم
الشل شمل في الواقع لان كل دول الاعضاء في
الجامعه العربيه
حاضره وستحضر اجتماعات القمه
وعوده سوريه الى مقرها ايضا
خطوه جديده
وخاصه مقارنه بالسنوات الاخيره اذا
هذه القمه قمه مهمه
وستناقش تحديات التي تواجهها العديد من
الدول العربيه مره اخرى اقول نحن على هامش
اجتماع قمه جده اللقاءات الثنائيه التي
عقدت حتى الان مع وزراء الخارجيه او
اللقاءات الثلاثيه وغيرها
هل يمكن ان نقول بان هذه القمه قمه جده
اللي حدث فيها اختراق الحقيقه دخلت في
سوريا الان عادت واحتلت مقعدها سيكون
الرئيس بشار الاسد الرئيس النظام السوري
حاضرا في هذه القمه هل يمكن ان نقول بان
ما بعد هذه القمه لن يكون قبلها في العمل
العربي المشترك طبعا
الخط الاساسي موجود بالفعل بين هذه القمه
والقمم الاخرى
انا وجود سوريا يعني تواجد سوريا في القمه
نقله نوعيه طبعا
لكن غياب السودان بشكل اخر ايضا
مهم
وسوداني الى اين
هذه سوف تؤثر على المستقبل العربي
لو نتحدث عن
التحديات الامنيه عندنا سوريا عندنا يمن
عندنا
الان سودان
لكن سودان وضع خاص سوداني القتال الداخلي
خطر خطر على اولا سودان لكن عند المنطقه
اذا لدينا تحديات جديده لكن لدينا ايضا
اضافات انه موجود سوريا في الجامعه
العربيه
لكي تناقش ايضا من وضع السوري هذا الوضع
السوري سواء من الناحيه الاقتصاديه ومن
ناحيه الانسانيه وضع خطر جدا
ولو استمر
الحاله حاله الحرب بين روسيا واوكرانيا
هذا يعني انه هناك
مشاكل بالنسبه للطاقه
والامن الغذائي يعني امن الطاقه وامن
الغذائي وامن الطاقه وامن الغذائي تؤثر
على كثير من دول وخاصه دول المحيطه
بالعراق سوريا مجتمع السوري
فالغلاء الفاحش
والتضخم العالمي تؤثر على هذه الدول فاذا
الوضع الاقتصادي والمجتمعي في سوريا في
خطر في الواقع اذا سؤال بعد عوده سوريا
الى الجامعه العربيه كيفيه تعامل مع هذا
الوضع الخطر في سوريا الوضع الاقتصادي
واللغه المجتمع لكن
الوضع الاقتصادي والمجتمعي في سوريا
الى اضافه اخرى ووضع الامني كيفيه التعامل
مع الوضع الامني في سوريا
الابعاد الاقتصاديه للحرب الاوكرانيه
الروسيه تؤثر على الاردن على مصر على كثير
من الدول يعني حتى نفهم ما الذي يحصل مع
سوريا هل عوده سوريا للجامعه العربيه يعني
انتهاء الازمه السوريه ام انها خطوه اولى
نحو مساعده سوريا على الخروج من ازماتها
وين راحت كل المعارضه
السوريه للجامعه العربيه لا تعني انتهاء
الازمه السوريه
عوده سوريا الى الجامعه العربيه يعني
اداره الازمه بشكل اخر بنسهل حياه الناس
شويه
اخر
وخلق فرص جديده لاداره الازمان يجب ان
نكون واقعين
الازمه السوريه ازمه داخليه
الازمه السوريه ازمه اقليميه الازمه
السوريه ازمه عالميه اذا
حل هذه المشكله يجب ان نقول على مستويات
مختلفه على مستوى الداخلي على مستوى
الاقليمي وعلى المستوى العالمي فلهذا اقول
انه عوده سوريا الى الجامعه العربيه لا
تعني انه ان الازمه ستحل لكن ستدار بشكل
اخر محاربه الفساد كان ايضا العراق متهم
انه من الدول اللي بتحتل مراكز متقدمه في
الدول المتعاني من عمليه فساد هل هل يمكن
المضي قدما دون محاربه الفساد سيدتي
نعم نعم العراق عانت من
الحروب واعتقد اذا ناخذ فتره الحروب
المختلفه سواء القتال الداخليه او الخارجي
العراق اعانت حوالي نصف قرن من الحروب
خمسين سنه
والحروب اي حرب
تخلق الفساد
يؤدي الى تدمير والدمار فالدمار وحالات
الحرب والفساد اصبحت ثقيله في المجتمع
العراقي نحن في الواقع نواجه تحدي كبير
التحدي الكبير الحكومه الحاليه بقياده
رئيس الوزراء محمد شيعه اللي نواجهها هي
مواجهه الفساد
لكن نحن نعترف ان هناك فساد
ونفكر كيفيه محاربه الفساد بعض المعالجات
الى علاقه
بتغيير النظام الاقتصادي النظام الاقتصادي
لحد الان لحد هذه اللحظه نظام يعتمد على
الكاش على في جزء كبير من التعامل المالي
نحن
بصدد ان نتوجه الى الاقتصاد الرقمي الى
تحويل مصارف هذه المسائل تحتاج الى وقت
اذا نحتاج الى تغيير البنيه الاقتصاديه
والماليه الى شكل اخر لكي نحارب من خلال
بناء البنيه التحتيه الفساد ولكن ايضا
الفساد الى علاقه بالثقافه يعني مساله
ثقافيه مساله فكريه مساله عقاريه يجب
محاربه الفساد في في مختلف الساحات
المهم الاولى لهذه الحكومه بالاضافه الى
بناء الاقصاد انهم هم مو الاولى مواجهه
الفساد بكافه اشكالها نحن نعترف ان هناك
فساد ولكن ايضا هناك خطط لمحاربه ليس
نيه هناك خطط ومعالجات بالحديث عن
الاقتصاد والمحاوله التنميه الاقتصاديه
داخل بغداد المستقره داخل العراق ايه
مشاريع خاصه ربما يتم الاتفاق عليها مع
المملكه العربيه السعوديه او تم الحديث
عنها منذ متى في الواقع نتباحث مع جانب
السعودي ومن مع جانب الخليجي اولا بالنسبه
لقضيه الكهرباء او الطاقه الكهربائيه
هناك تفاهمات وفي الواقع اتفقت مع جانب
السعودي للشراء الطاقه الكهربائيه من الخط
السعودي وايضا هناك اتفاق لشراء الكهرباء
من الخط الخليجي الكويت اذا مساله
الكهرباء كانت
خلال سنوات الاخيره جزءا من هذه الاتفاقات
ولكن ايضا
المملكه
تستطيع ان تلعبوا شركات خاصه في المملكه
تستطيع ان تلعب دورا في
بناء الاقتصاد العراقي وخاصه في مجال
الاستثمارات سواء الاستثمارات
البتروكيماويه
والاستثمارات في مجال الزراعه
وفي مجالات اخرى ونحن بصدد
بناء خط للسكك الحديديه من ميناء الفاو
الى
الى تركيا وبالتالي الى اوروبا
وتمديد هذا الخط الى جانب السعودي هذا مهم
تجاريه
هناك مشاريع كبيره هذه المشاريع الكبيره
مثل الوضع الامني او
الحاله الاقتصاديه العامه لا يمكن بناءها
اذا لم يكن هناك تعاون اقليمي اذا التعاون
الاقتصادي الاقليمي وخاصه في هذا صدى
التعاون بين دول الخليجيه والعراق على
الاجنده ومباحثات مستمره قبل ايام كانت
هناك وفد من احدى الدول الخليجيه في بغداد
للشركات
الخليجيه اذا الشركات الخليجيه بصوره عامه
وشركات السعوديه بصوره خاصه تستطيع ان
تلعب دورا مهما في الاستثمار في العراق
وبناء الاقتصاد العراقي الاقتصاد العراقي
خاصه البنى التحتيه مدمره مدمره بسبب ظروف
الحرب
واذا نحتاج الى بناء
ونحتاج الى خبره ونوهو
شركات الخليجيه تستطيع ان تلعب دورا مهما
في هذا المجال بالاضافه طبعا الى شركات
الغربيه علاقه العراق بالولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لم تتاثر بكل الظروف التي مرت
في العراق يعني في سنوات
الغضب الشديد الامريكي من ايران كانت
العلاقه مع العراق قائمه لمصلحه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ولمصلحه العراق ايضا
الان مع الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه العلاقه
قائمه المواقف العراقيه دائما يعني حتى لو
كانت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لا ترضى
عنها بشكل كبير الا انها
تعبر عن
يعني لا تعبر عن حاله
غضب او عدم رضا من قبل امريكا اين تضع لي
العلاقه الامريكيه العراقيه الان في حاله
الاستقرار العراقي الان العلاقه الامريكيه
العراقيه تتطور
بصوره صحيه كانت العلاقه العراقيه
الامريكيه
تتركز
على المواضيع الامنيه والعسكريه الان
تحولنا الى المواضيع الاقتصاديه الثقافيه
صحيه
الدبلوماسيه ولكن علاقات قويه
وسوف نحافظ على هذه العلاقات لان من مصلحه
العراق
ان تكون لنا علاقات قويه مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه مع اوروبا
اذا جزء
ونستند اساسا على المسرح العراقيه لتقويه
هذه العلاقات واستمرار فيه ولكن في مراحل
مختلفه او مرحله معينه
دخلت
هذه العلاقه مرحله حساسه حينما كان هناك
توتر شديد بين
طهران واشنطن ودفعنا ثمن في مرحله معينه
دفعنا ثمان هذا التوتر الشديد لهذا نحن
ايضا من دعاه انه ان يكون هناك حوار بين
الجانب الايراني والامريكي لان اي توترات
سواء اقليميه او توترات اقليميه مع امريكا
تؤثر على الوضع العراقي لان علاقاتنا مع
اجانب الامريكيه علاقات قويه فحينما
تكون هناك توترات بين دوله معينه وخاصه
ايران ايضا دوله جاره وعلاقات قويه مع
العراق مع الجانب الامريكي نحن ندفع الثمن
المؤسسه العسكريه العراقيه هل اصبحت بشكل
واضح ونهائي قادره على حمايه الحدود الان
يعني الحدود مع ايران الحدود مع سوريا
يعني كان دائما ما تتهم العراق بانها بسبب
ضعف المؤسسات العسكريه وساضعف قوات الحدود
يتم يعني خروج ودخول الارهابيين او
الدواعش او القاعده هل مؤسسه العراقيه
قادره على حمايه العسكريه العراقيه متنوعه
لدينا
العسكر لدينا الحشد الشعبي لدينا القوات
لدينا القوات الامنيه
فلو ناخذ كل هذه المؤسسات المؤسسات قويه
في مواجهه الارهاب
الفلسفه السياسيه
العسكريه العراقيه ليست في مواجهه دول
الجوار نحن نسعى دوما حتى ولو كانت هناك
تدخلات او خلافات مع دول الجوار نسعى الى
حل مشاكل من خلال الحوار وليس من خلال
استخدام الادوات العسكريه او الامنيه لحل
هذه المشاكل
حينما
تتداخل تركيا
في في الاراضي العراقيه طبعا هناك بعض
الاصوات في الساحل العراقيه انه نواجه
تركيا عسكريه
لكن هذا الفكر خطا
لام التجربه العراقيه السابقه يجب ان ناخذ
دروس من التجربه العراقيه السابقه
بكل الحروب اللي دخلت فيها العراق بنتيجه
العراق خسرت محتمل الاخرين اخرين ايضا
خسروا لان اذا ننطلق من مفهوم انه الحرب
يعني
النفس ودمار الاخر ودمار الاخر اذا يجب ان
نخلق فضاء اخر في المنطقه فضاء الحوار وعن
طريق الحوار والنقاش نصل الى حل هذه
المشاكل هناك ازمات صحيحه
والاتراك يتدخلون في الاراضي العراقيه هم
يقولون انه يتدخلون بسبب وجود قوات العمال
حزب العمال الكردستاني
ونحن لدينا دستور ودستور يشير الى بصوره
واضحه انه
منع اي قوه عسكريه او قوه سياسيه تحاول
انه الهجوم على دوله جاره من
الاراضي العراقيه اذا نحن لجينا واجبات
الى علاقه بالدستور العراقي
ويجب ان
نحاول حل هذه المشكله داخليا ولكن هذا لا
يعني ان لتركيا الحق حتى من الناحيه قانون
الدولي
الدخول الى الاراضي العراقيه اذا يجب ان
نصل الى
تفاهمات مع جانب التركي لكي نحل هذه
المشاكل عن طريق الحوار ونحن
نستفاد من هذا المسار ومستمرين في الحوار
مع جانب التركي حمايه الحدود بين سوريا
والعراق بين العراق بين سوريا من
تم بناء
يعني
اسلاك يعني وضعت اسلاك شائكه على الحدود
حتى
يكون من الصعوبه للارهابيين العبور من
الجانب السوري الى
الجانب العراقي
والجيش العراقي وقوات
الحشد الشعبي ايضا مترابط على على الحدود
السوريه العراقيه لمنع الارهابيين اخذنا
درس من
من
الماضي حينما هجمت الارهابيين قوات
ارهابيه من الجانب السوري الى العراق فتم
اتخاذ الاجراءات اللازمه والخطوات لحمايه
الحدود اعتقد حمايتها حدود العراقيه سوريا
الان جيده
الحقيقه لا يملل الحديث معك معالي الوزير
الف شكر لك على هذه اللقاء اللي منحتني
اياه ومشاهدينا الكرام سنتابع واياكم
المزيد من اللقاءات مع المزيد من الشخصيات
على هامش قمه جده كان معنا في هذه
المقابله نائب رئيس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه
العراقي علي السيد فؤاد حسين الى اللقاء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات